KOBI GLICK: Hi, everyone.
I'm Kobi, a product
manager on Google Play.
MILENA NIKOLIC: And I'm
Milena, engineering manager
on Google Play.
We work on Play Apps
Developer team in London.
Today, we are here
to tell you how
you can set your app for
success using some of the tools
that we provide in Google
Play Developer Console.
We'll talk about rapid
iteration and experimentation,
and we'll tell you how
some developers are
using these services to
have success on Play.
KOBI GLICK: The
vision of our team
is to build powerful
publishing tools, allowing
you to launch and iterate.
We believe that experimentation
is the key to success.
Throughout this
presentation, you'll
see a lot of developer
feedback, and we'll
start with the feedback we
have from Michael Ritter, SVP
Business Development at
SGN, about why they released
"Genies & Gems" Android first.
The quick publishing time
on Google Play is the key.
You can make multiple
submissions in a short time,
iterating on your product.
Rapid iteration
and experimentation
is the key to success.
SGN are power users of tools
like beta testing and Store
Listing Experiments.
We will show you how
other developers are
using these tools, and we will
share some best practices.
SGN use our tools, and then
they utilize their finding
across platforms.
This leads to a much more
efficient soft-launch process.
Soft launching is
a great way to make
sure your app or game
delivers value to users.
As a result, their
worldwide launch
was much more
successful, and this
is exactly what we have
in mind when we are
building those tools for you.
Our goal is to help
you experiment,
launch, and iterate fast.
MILENA NIKOLIC: We
got a similar feedback
from Concrete
Software, developers
of "PBA Bowling Challenge."
They've told us that they
soft launch on Android first,
because it allows
them to iterate faster
and to launch kind
of in a better way.
This is exactly
music to our ears,
exactly the feedback
we like to hear,
and a practice we would
like to encourage.
KOBI GLICK: So what are
we going to talk about?
MILENA NIKOLIC:
OK, so we're going
to start by talking
about beta testing
and some of the improvements
we are making to this service
to make it even easier to
run large beta programs
and to get feedback
from your users.
Then we'll talk
about the best way
to roll out these rapid changes
in a safe and controlled
fashion.
Then we'll go on to talk
about how you can understand
your users, using
user position report,
and how you can optimize
your user acquisition using
Store Listing Experiments.
We will also talk about the
importance of experimentation
if you're looking to go globally
and localize your app to all
the global markets.
And finally, we will
also touch on how
you can keep an eye on the
performance of your app
on the go using new
Play Console mobile app.
Throughout this session,
we'll mention new features
that we launched
recently or the ones
that we're launching
today or very soon.
KOBI GLICK: OK, so let's
start with beta testing.
This is a great way to
improve your apps and games.
60% of the top 1,000
apps on Google Play
are running a beta
test right now.
And the goal is obviously
to test your apps and games
with testers and early adopters.
It used to be challenging
in the past to join beta,
so we launched closed
and open betas.
With open beta, it's as
simple clicking the URL.
MILENA NIKOLIC: Did
you know that there
are many big apps that are
running very large open beta
programs?
For example,
"Minecraft," Uber, Google
Search app, and many others.
KOBI GLICK: Nice.
So here's a great
example of a developer
that is using this platform
in a very correct way.
Hopper, an app helping
travelers make better decisions,
they run an internal alpha
testing and then a much larger
public beta test.
And you can see
from their feedback
it cuts through testing
and rollout time by half
without adding any extra work
for them or their testers.
This is exactly what we had in
mind when we built this model.
We're making it even
easier for users
to discover and
join beta testing.
Very soon, users will be able
to join beta tests directly
through your Store listing
page on Google Play.
So if you run an open
beta, you can just
tell users, go to our page.
Click it there.
Join our beta, and
give us feedback.
Feedback.
You used to collect feedback
through various sources
and had to parse a
lot of information.
From now on, users that
are part of your beta test
will be able to submit private
feedback to you directly
through Google Play.
This feedback is private.
You can see it in the Google
Play Developer Console.
It doesn't show to other
users, and it doesn't
impact your app's star rating.
Now, we believe
that apps and games
should be launching open
beta even before they go live
in production.
This is why soon we
are going to introduce
a new section on Google
Play called Early Access.
In this section, we will
feature exciting apps and games
that are still in
development and haven't
launched to production yet.
This will allow
developers, you guys,
to test your apps early on, with
early adopters and influencers
giving you private
feedback, making
sure you can find product
market fit earlier
or find tune your game's KPIs.
In our first
collection, we are going
to introduce 28 apps and games.
You can see them up here.
Pretty cool icons.
We have for example, Readfeed.
It's an Android-first
online book club.
Or we have Ava.
The founder, whose parents
and sisters are deaf,
created this app to help
deaf people and people
with hearing disabilities
to participate
in real-life conversations.
Then we have LEGO, the kids'
and family power brand,
with their first ever
in-house mobile game.
It's a 3D LEGO set.
You can touch, twist,
just like the brick
sets we all grew up with.
Now, Early Access is not going
to be just for free to play.
"Never Alone" a gorgeous game
developed by E-Line Media
and researched together
with the Alaskan natives,
is coming to Google
Play on Early Access.
They chose Early Access
because it's a great way
to make sure they get
feedback from their fans
and making sure the gaming
experience is a premium one.
We are sure those changes that
we are doing to beta testing
will help you create
larger beta tests,
making your apps and
games even more awesome.
MILENA NIKOLIC: OK.
Kobi mentioned
that users will be
able to give private
feedback on open beta apps.
I know you all
know how important
it is to listen to user
feedback and to act on it.
Recently, we have
launched a number
of improvements to user
reviews functionality
in Google Play
Developer Console,
allowing you to, for example,
search your reviews by keyword.
Or, for example, to see various
breakdowns of rating aggregates
by a number of
different dimensions,
for example, device, country,
app version, and so on.
In addition to that, we
made it possible to sign up
for email notifications
when users change
their review after your reply.
I'm happy to announce that today
we launched Review Analysis.
These are further
improvements to user reviews
functionality in Google
Play Developer Console,
and they come in
several different tools.
One of them is benchmarks across
a number of fixed aspects,
for example, design,
stability, or speed.
So it basically
allows you to compare
how your app is doing
comparing to other similar apps
on these fixed aspects.
In addition to this, we
also launched unique topics.
So analyzing all of
your user reviews
and trying to extract what
are those specific topics
that users are talking
about just for your app.
OK.
Let's talk about release
management tools.
KOBI GLICK: Sounds good.
MILENA NIKOLIC: Cool.
So you beta tested your app.
You addressed a bunch
of user feedback.
And now, you want to
launch to production.
In this critical moment in time,
we want to be there for you.
We want to give you as
much support as we can
so you can roll out in a very
safe and controlled fashion.
One feature that I want
to remind everyone of
is staged rollouts.
Staged rollouts allow you
to roll out gradually,
keeping an eye on the
performance of your app
so that you can halt
in case of any issues.
In case issues do
happen-- and we all
know that they do-- you
will be able to halt,
and you will only
unhalt if you very,
very specifically-- if you
do that action or upload
a new set of APKs.
And here is one power tip.
When you start a
staged rollout, we
select a random percentage
of users who become eligible
for this new update.
If you increase the
percentage, we add more users
to the randomly selected set.
If you start the
next staged rollout,
we use a completely
different seed,
which means it's not always
the same set of users
getting less stable
versions, so you
don't have to worry about that.
For example, you can see how
developers like FTX Games
use staged rollouts
to confidently roll
out and frequently roll out
new versions of their app.
KOBI GLICK: OK.
So since we're talking
about release management,
I wanted to mention another
feature we launched recently
called Timed Publishing.
We know that you appreciate
the quick publishing
times available on Google Play.
But we wanted to
do better, meaning
giving you exact control on
the moment your app update goes
live.
With Timed Publishing, you
can make as many changes,
like APK changes, Store
listing updates, as you wish.
We batch all the changes,
and they don't go live
until you click the Go Live
button in the Google Play
Developer Console.
When you click it, the changes
go live within minutes.
You also have a
changes log showing you
exactly what changes
are about to go
live, which is a great way
to manage your release.
You can see the feedback
from Flaregames here
showing us how this feature
is super useful for them.
MILENA NIKOLIC: OK.
Now, let's talk
about understanding
visits to your Store
listing page in Google Play.
It's very important
to understand where
your users are coming from.
And sometime last year, we
launched User Acquisition
Funnel.
This funnel allows you to see
how many visitors to your Store
listing are being
converted to installers
and how many of those
installers are then converting
to become in-app purchasers.
In addition to this, you can
further break down this report
by, for example, user
acquisition source or channel.
For example, seeing
whether users
are coming from
places organically
or from different
channels, like advertising.
I'm pretty sure
that, like Trulia,
so far you've found this
report to be very useful.
And since understanding where
your users are coming from
is so important,
a couple of weeks
ago we have launched
another improvement
to this panel, which allows you
to break it down by country.
This is very
important, because it
allows you to localize your
app in a more efficient way.
And to take it one
step further, we're
happy to announce that very soon
we will be launching conversion
funnel benchmarks.
This will allow
you to compare how
your app is doing against
other similar apps in terms
of how efficiently it's
converting users from visitors
to Store listing
page to installers.
Stay tuned.
This is coming very soon.
And once you see who's visiting
your Store listing page,
you'll want to optimize, right?
KOBI GLICK: Yup.
MILENA NIKOLIC: Right.
OK, so let's talk about
getting you some more users.
To do that, we want to make sure
that your Store listing really
shows off your app in
the best possible light.
And in order to get to
the best Store listing,
we need to experiment.
This is where Store Listing
Experiments come in.
This feature has been
a very big success
with developers
in the past year.
More than 70% of
our top developers
are using the feature.
We often get feedback from
developers, for example,
like this one from
Goodgame Studios,
that it drives significant
uplift to their conversion
rate.
KOBI GLICK: A big opportunity
to get more installs
is optimizing the top of the
funnel, your Store listing
page.
This is where users make
their install decision,
regardless of whether they
found the app through Search
or via a deep link.
Before we launched it, you had
to use a bunch of workarounds
and spend some budget.
You can see the
feedback from Rovio
here on how they had
to run icon tests.
They spent budget.
After we launched it, you
can see their feedback
about soft launching
first on Google Play
as it allows them to better
understand their users.
Store Listing Experiments have
been seeing great success.
In the last year, you can
see Flaregames up here,
30% increase in installs.
ERepublik Labs, running
this exactly the way we
thought about it, as a rapid
iteration and experimentation
tool.
Expedia, 10% increase
of installs globally.
And actually, their
most successful test
was reordering screenshots.
MILENA NIKOLIC: Here
are some best practices
when running Store
Listening Experiments.
Create a hypothesis first.
Make sure you know what
you're trying to prove.
Next, test one thing at a time.
Run your experiments
until they have reached
statistical significance.
We'll let you know
when this has happened.
Minor tweaks often
have minor impact.
Consider bold
changes, especially
if you're early in
your startup's life.
And finally, keep testing.
The next major improvement
may be still to come.
Here is some great feedback
we received from Jamie Berger,
head of marketing at Scopely.
We can see how this
feature encourages
testing and validation
of new and bold ideas.
We were very happy to
see how they used this
as their go-to tool for market
testing and optimization.
KOBI GLICK: OK, so here's
some great examples
of the best practices in
action with Instacart.
We've learned that an
app description that
clearly shows your app value
to users just works better.
So you can see control
versus experiment.
Experiment is much clearer.
Plus 14% in installs.
And here's a bunch
of great examples
from Concrete Software.
Sometimes, you just get lucky.
They run an icon test for
"NHL Hockey Target Smash."
Plus 70% installs.
Boom.
It's great, right?
But sometimes, you actually
need to launch, iterate,
and experiment a lot.
So with "PBA Bowling
Challenge," they
ran a series of experiments,
and every icon that you see here
represents a complete
series of experiments.
They also iterated on their
description, screenshots,
and their order, leading to
a compound effect of 63%.
This is incredible.
Now, let's see an example from
mixi, a leading game developer
from Japan, that will
show us how a leading game
developer thinks
about localization
and experimentation.
When mixi wanted to take
their big hit "Monster
Strike" to the US, they ran
a series of experiments.
They tested the icon, the
screenshots, the description,
and the video.
In this chart, you can see
how they ran the experiments
methodically and scientifically,
leading to a compound effect
of 68% in installs.
Start Listing
Experiments helped mixi
understand the difference
in taste and flavor
between users in the
US and users in Japan
and help them localized
their games much better.
And here's the feedback we got
from their XFLAG Studio team.
This feedback makes
us really excited,
as our mission is to help you
test directly on our platform.
MILENA NIKOLIC: We
want you to experiment,
we want you to iterate, and
we want you to do this fast.
This is why I'm happy to
announce that last week,
we launched multiple concurrent
localized Store Listing
Experiments.
We want you to go globally
faster and have better tools
to test localized versions
of your Store listing.
You can now run up
to five Experiments
with different languages
at the same time.
KOBI GLICK: Awesome.
So you're talking about
making things faster, right?
MILENA NIKOLIC: Indeed.
KOBI GLICK: One
thing that is not
fast today is making price
changes in the Developer
Console.
This really sucks, actually.
Because lots of people
have the same price
point to many in-app
products or paid apps.
So what are we going
to do about that?
MILENA NIKOLIC: I'm very
glad you asked, Kobi.
We want to make
this faster as well.
pricing faster as well.
So I'm also happy to announce
that earlier this week,
we have launched
Pricing Templates.
With Pricing Templates,
you can define prices
across all of the markets
that Google Play supports.
Did you guys know that there
are 70 such markets now?
Yeah.
Once you create a
template, you can link it
to as many paid apps or
in-app products as you want.
If you make a change
to a template,
it gets propagated
to all of the apps.
So, for example, if you're
like Toca Boca Games
and selling multiple titles
at, let's say, $2.99,
you only need to make changes
to your template once,
and it will be propagated
to all of your apps.
If you're like Wooga,
selling in-app products
at multiple price points,
for example, $1.99, $4.99,
and $9.99, you only need
to maintain three templates
instead of manually
making changes
to tens or hundreds
of individual pricing
points in multiple
different currencies.
Like in this feedback
we got from Toca Boca,
we hope Pricing Templates
will help you move faster
and get successful.
KOBI GLICK: OK.
So it's important
for us you're also
able to localize
your price better.
This is why we also
launched Round Pricing.
With Round Pricing, we're
not, like we used to do,
just converting the price
using today's exchange rate.
We also apply locally relevant,
country-specific rounding
rules.
So a price like 9.73
euros becomes 9.99 euros.
A price like 196
Japanese yen simply
becomes 200 Japanese yen.
And 25,235 Indonesian
rupee simply
becomes 25,000 Indonesian rupee.
We are sure that this change,
like the feedback you see here
from Wooga, will help you
streamline your pricing
structures and make your
businesses even better.
Now, while we're helping you
make price changes faster
with templates and more
locally relevant with rounding,
we're keeping your ability
to tweak the prices manually
in the Developer Console.
We know that this
is important for you
when you run a
short-time promotion
or try new pricing strategies.
We are sure that the new
changes we are making to pricing
will help you go
globally faster.
MILENA NIKOLIC: OK.
Last but not least.
Finally, we have a mobile
app for Google Play Developer
Console.
We have to admit,
it took us awhile.
It took us much longer than
it took all of you guys,
but we've made it.
And we can tell you this
app stuff is pretty sweet.
We really like it now.
Our new app allows you to
follow your app's performance
on the go and to do
time-critical changes wherever
you are.
When you're rapidly
iterating, you
need a power tool that's in
your pocket at all times,
and we've built Play Console
app exactly with those use cases
in mind.
Whether you want to quickly
reply to a user review
or show off performance of your
app to a venture capitalist,
Play Console app should
be there to support you.
Regarding an
initial feature set,
obviously, you can track
installs and uninstalls,
and you can break them down
by a number of dimensions,
like app version, country,
device, and so on.
You can also track
your crash reports,
including hourly data
and full stack traces.
You can also see ratings
and user reviews,
and you can reply
to user reviews.
You can also track the
state of your release.
For example, is it
in beta testing,
is it in staged rollout,
or has it reached prod yet?
Oh, and one more thing.
You can obviously get
push notifications--
everyone loves
those-- when there
are certain important
changes to your app.
For example, when your
app updates go live.
If you haven't installed
the app yet, please do.
If you're still not convinced,
please come to Play Sandbox.
We would love to convince you.
And if you have any
feedback, send it to us.
We intend to listen and
add more functionality
in the next couple of versions.
KOBI GLICK: OK.
So today, we spoke about
launching, experiment,
and iterating on Google Play.
With the new changes we're going
to introduce to beta tests,
it will become easier for
users to discover and join
your beta programs
and for you to build
bigger, larger beta audiences
and improve your apps
and games.
Users will be able to
send you private feedback
that only you can see in
the Developer Console.
The new Early
Access section will
feature exciting apps and games
that are still in development.
We also spoke about
better understanding users
with our new mobile app
that Milena just mentioned
and a bunch of enhancements,
such as benchmark,
to the user acquisition report.
Finally, we spoke about
making things faster
with multiple localized Store
Listing Experiments and price
templates, as well as
making prices more locally
relevant with rounding.
We are really excited to
getting developer feedback
like the one you see here from
Scott Rubin, SVP of business
development at
ROBLOX, telling us
how features like Store
Listing Experiments
encouraged them to launch their
next major update on Android
first.
We hope that the
tools we're building
will encourage you to continue
to launching and iterating
on our platform.
We will continue to help
build more powerful publishing
tools, allowing
you to experiment,
iterate, and make your apps
and games even more awesome.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MILENA NIKOLIC: Thank you.
Now, I would like to invite to
the stage Larissa and Aaron.
AARON ROTHMAN: Thank you.
LARISSA FONTAINE:
Thanks, Milena and Kobi.
That was an amazing overview of
all of the cool stuff launching
in the Developer Console.
You can see that Aaron and I are
really excited about this talk
today, so much so that we
decided to dress the part.
How you doing there, Indy?
My name's Larissa, and I
lead business development
for the Apps team
at Google Play.
My team and I work
with developers
to help them build great apps
and successful businesses
on the platform.
AARON ROTHMAN: And I'm Aaron.
I lead search and
discovery on Play.
My team is focused on making
sure users find great apps.
LARISSA FONTAINE: As much
as I love Short Round,
I'm going to take the hat
off so I can see you guys.
So I talk to developers
all the time,
and understanding how Store
discovery works always
comes up as an important topic.
We know that it can
feel difficult to break
through the noise and to help
users find your app at exactly
the right time.
More apps are being uploaded
to the Store every day,
making it even harder
to break through.
And studies show that more users
are using the same set of apps
over and over again instead
of downloading new ones.
One theory is that app
fatigue is driving this.
But what if it's
that users simply
can't find all the great
apps that are out there?
And it's not only
apps that are growing.
The entire Android ecosystem
is growing incredibly fast.
You heard some of these
numbers this morning.
The one we're going
to talk about here
is 1 billion
monthly Store users.
Out of that huge
audience, we want
to help you find the
best users for your app.
So that's why you're all here.
Today, we're going
to walk through how
we can work together to improve
app discovery in the Play
Store.
There are a lot of
important elements
that contribute to
discovery, and some of which
you've already heard about.
But we're going to
touch on a few of them
again, because
they're that important
and because they directly
contribute to discovery.
We've narrowed them down
to the most critical,
and we're going to go
through each of them--
build something great,
listen to your users,
optimize your presence,
and expand your reach.
And then we're going to
share some insights about how
the discovery
mechanisms in the Store
actually work, some of which
we've never shared before.
AARON ROTHMAN: So as
Larissa mentioned, it all
starts with building
something great.
We want users to find
the apps they will love.
So a quarter of installed
apps are used only once.
Wow, that's scarier
than a pit of snakes.
LARISSA FONTAINE: All right,
Aaron, let's turn it back.
AARON ROTHMAN: Anyways,
anyways, I promise no more.
So this is where
we want to start
with building something great.
So based on some
internal analysis,
we found that permissions,
footprint, and design
were all key components
when it came to a user's
perception of a great app.
So starting with permissions.
Excessive permissions
can actually
deter a user from installing
your app in the first place.
It's important to
remember-- if you don't
need it, don't ask for it.
Users may be wary
of installing apps
where the permissions don't
seem to align with the app
functionality.
For example, why
does a child's game
need to access my
phone's call logs?
Second is footprint.
Some users may be scared off
by the footprint of your app.
These users may be on
poor internet connections
or have limited phone memory.
This is especially true
in emerging markets,
where there are both phone
and network limitations.
So it's helpful to be mindful
of SDK compatibility, APK
size, and memory usage.
Sometimes, less is more.
Third is design.
So the users installed your app.
Now, you want to ensure
a great experience.
So remember to limit
the cognitive load.
A well-designed app is
intuitive and consistent
and does not require
a user to hunt,
guess, remember,
or otherwise strain
their brains trying
to figure out
how to interact with your app.
One tangible solution for
making a highly usable app
is implementing Google's design
spec, known as material design.
Here are two examples of apps
that invested more in quality
by adopting material
design, which
led to the benefit of
more user engagement.
It's pretty impressive,
for example,
that Trello saw a 41% increase
in activity per session
by implementing material design.
So you can do your best
to build a great app.
But how can you be sure
it's actually great?
More than half of poor user
reviews are quality related,
and a third of those are
just about bugs and crashes.
It can be difficult to get it
right in the first iteration.
So we recommend following
the earlier advice of Milena
and Kobi and using beta
testing and staged rollouts
to ensure that your app
is great when it launches.
So we've covered building
and launching a great app.
Now, just because
your app is launched,
it doesn't mean you need to
stop engaging with your users.
Listening to your users
is important for continued
success, and I'm
going to explain why.
You have a unique
opportunity in Android
to engage with
your users directly
by replying to the reviews
via the Developer Console
and building an even more
loved app as a result.
One example is Aviary,
who created a dialogue
with their users by
engaging with feedback.
This responsiveness
led to 50% of reviewers
revising their scores higher.
It's crazy, right?
User feedback can help
make your app better,
leading to higher
ratings and a boost
in discovery opportunities.
LARISSA FONTAINE: So
after building a great app
and listening to
your users, it's
important to create a
Play Store listing that
quickly and accurately reflects
what your app is about.
You're all familiar with
the different elements
of your listing.
These really require some
thoughtful attention.
We've provided
multiple ways for you
to communicate the value of
your app, and it's up to you
to ensure they capture the
most important and interesting
information.
And each of them, from the
title to the description
to the images,
provide metadata that
help us understand
what your app does
and who's most likely to use it.
It sounds easy, but no one
gets it right the first time.
And this is why we created Store
Listing Experiments to help you
refine each of these elements.
You already heard
from Kobi and Milena
about how these have helped
developers over the last year.
And the stat that
70% of top developers
are using Experiments
is really incredible.
Developers of all sizes
are seeing real impact.
And iteration is key for
Store Listening Experiments.
In this example from
Rovio, they focused
on the icon and finding
which one would most
impact conversions.
Here are 12 different
treatments they explored,
with various outcomes.
And they kept iterating.
This is what we see
from developers who
are finding the most success.
They continue to test
and refine and understand
user preferences.
Ultimately, Rovio saw
significant uplift
as a result of
their Experiments.
And back to discovery.
Higher conversion rates from
your listing to installs
are an important
signal, and they
help us understand when
a user has successfully
gone from searching for
an app to finding one
that they think they'll love.
So now, you've
built a great app,
you've implemented
important feedback,
and you have a strong
Play Store presence.
What's next?
There are different
opportunities
to expand your reach,
depending on the type of app
you have and the type of
experiences that your users
are looking for.
Going global and finding
audiences in new markets
is a strategy that's
worked extremely well
for many developers,
so we're going
to explore a few tips and tools
that can help you find success
in new markets.
So earlier, we talked about
the massive reach of Android.
We've actually looked
at the growth rates
of apps that are
available globally
and those that are only
available in specific markets.
Global apps grew 2.4 times
faster than non-global apps.
Now, this makes intuitive sense.
If you have more markets,
you have a larger addressable
audience.
But the data really
proves it out.
There are a few specific
things to consider when you're
planning to localize your app.
First, you should use
the Dev Console reports
that we talked about to
understand where new user
bases are growing and prioritize
localizing for those markets.
Second, don't just
translate, actually localize.
This means ensure
that you're culturally
aware of local
market expectations
and be ready to
support your new users.
Last, always be prepared
to test and iterate.
New users means new feedback.
A developer who did incredibly
well with this is 1Password.
They localized their Store
description, their screenshots,
the content, and the
messaging inside their app.
And we looked at those
signals to understand
when the app was ready to
be shown to local users.
For 1Password, the
investment really paid off.
After two weeks of work,
they saw 100x install growth
in Korea.
It was really pretty incredible.
By focusing on
local market users,
they made a real difference.
And in most cases,
it's worth the effort
if your plan is to grow
through market expansion.
And we have powerful tools to
help, like the localization
checklist, access to
translation services,
and the new pricing
features that Kobi shared.
So we've reviewed the
most important ways
that you can directly
affect the discoverability
of your app and some key actions
that you can take right away.
For build something
great, limit permissions,
and focus on beautiful design.
Listen to your users.
Feedback is a gift.
Use it to get better.
Optimize your presence.
Experiment your way to
improve conversions.
And expand your reach.
Go global and localize.
We've also mentioned that
all of these impact discovery
within the Store.
So let's unpack how the
Store actually works
and why each of these
elements matter.
AARON ROTHMAN: Uh-oh.
There we go.
I'm back.
Great.
So how are users actually
discovering apps in Play,
and what matters to those
discovery mechanisms?
So let's start with
how users are actually
finding apps today.
The top discovery
channels on Play
are number one, Play Search,
two, Recommendations, three,
Top Charts.
So starting with Search.
About half of searches are
specifically for an app title.
This is where it's especially
important when naming your app
to be unique, keep it short, and
make sure that it is not easily
confused with a
similarly named app.
A well-named app
also has the benefit
of appearing within
Google Play Search
Suggest, which makes it
even easier for users
to find your app.
By using Google
Play Search Suggest,
they don't even need to type in
the full name to find the app.
Half of searches are also
by category or keyword.
This is where it's
important to make sure you
select the right app category.
Also, when you're writing
the description of your app,
it's great and important to
be thorough and complete,
making sure to include key
functionality and features.
You may have noticed
there's actually
a third way that an app can
appear within given search
results, and this is ads.
Play Search ads are already
part of AdWords' app
install campaigns and provide
an additional placement
within Play Search.
So Recommendations.
Whether on the Home page
or right after a user
installs an app, Google Play
recommends apps personalized
for each user.
Although there are
a lot of components
that go into those
smarts, I just
want to highlight a
few for you today.
These include metadata, app
quality, user Store activity,
and web knowledge.
LARISSA FONTAINE: So
charts are a common way
for both new and returning users
to gain a quick understanding
of which apps are
popular in the Store
and which apps are on their
way to becoming popular.
So we're going to
share some insight
into how these charts
are put together,
with specific details
on key components.
Top Free and Top Paid
charts are primarily
determined by installs
within the last seven days.
We've kept this
timeline fairly short,
because we want the charts to
stay fresh and interesting week
over week.
Top New Free and
Top New Paid also
look back at installs over
the previous seven days,
but they're biased
towards new apps, those
that have launched on the
Store in the previous 30 days.
This is important to make sure
the charts aren't dominated
by established titles.
We want to help users find new
and interesting apps wherever
they look for them.
Trending, on the
other hand, identifies
fast risers that
have the potential
to make it onto the top charts.
Typically, this means
that their installs have
seen accelerated growth
over the previous 30 days,
but their absolute
installs might not
be as large as those on
the other top charts.
And finally, Top Grossing uses
the same seven-day trailing
approach but is instead
determined by spend.
And of course, we're always
tuning our algorithms
to produce the best
user experience,
so these are subject to change.
But hopefully, you
have a better sense
of what drives placement
in the top charts
and how we look
at user preference
to determine which
apps to surface.
Featuring.
Everybody loves featuring.
So we define featuring to
mean the collections that
appear across the store,
either manually curated
or algorithmically generated.
Quality is the key
driver for inclusion,
and that's why we spent the
first half of this talk focused
on tools and strategies to
help drive important quality
signals.
In addition to
quality, we also want
to surface trending apps
to keep the Store fresh,
and we definitely
want users to find
apps that are using the
latest Android features,
things that truly make their
experience and their phone
special.
If you meet the
necessary quality bar,
your app is eligible
for appearing
in certain collections where
it makes contextual sense,
fits a category or
topic, or where users
have installed similar apps.
With an even higher
expectation of quality,
we have collections showcasing
new and updated apps,
so users know they're getting
great experiences that
are hot off the presses.
For seasonal collections
and special promotions,
our BD and merchandising
teams work together
to identify which
apps to include.
And we also use a
healthy dose of machine
learning to scale our efforts
across categories and markets.
It's important to
note that within each
of these collections, the
Recommendations engine helps
determine which
users see which apps.
The most important thing is
not that millions of users
see your app, it's that millions
of the right users see your app
and go on to install it.
AARON ROTHMAN: So now that we
revealed the Holy Grail of app
discovery-- ha--
LARISSA FONTAINE: Ha.
AARON ROTHMAN: --we
want to leave you
with four recommendations
that you can do right now.
Number one, for
building a great app,
we recommend reviewing
Android's design principles.
Does your app measure up?
Two, for listening
to your users,
we recommend addressing user
feedback, especially when it
comes to bugs.
Squash those bugs.
Number three, for
optimizing your presence,
why not try a Store
Listing Experiment?
And finally, number four,
for expanding your reach,
we recommend reviewing
the market report
in the Developer Console.
So that's our talk for today.
We're so excited to
have you all here.
We know we shared a lot
of content with you,
but the great news
is that you can
find everything you need
in our new app, Playbook
by Google Play.
It replaces the business
guide that some of you
have seen called "The Secrets
to App Success on Google Play."
There are a ton of great
features, but it's brand new.
So we would love your feedback.
If you get a moment, please hop
over to the Google Play Store
and try it out.
And of course, we want to leave
you with a few helpful links.
Thank you so much for
coming from all of us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]